Good day, everyone.
This is Jack Van Horn from the University
of Southern California, and I'd like to welcome
you
to the Big Data to Knowledge Guide to the
Fundamentals of Data Science.
We're very pleased to have Ravi Madduri speaking
with us today on the subject of Big Data Technologies
For
Biomedical Knowledge Discovery.
Ravi Madduri is a senior computational scientist
based at the University of
Chicago as well as the Argonne National Laboratory.
His research interests are in large scale
computation and
data management, and he leads the Globist
Genomics Project, which uses genomics, proteomics,
and other
biomedical computations on cloud-based and
other HCP platforms.
He received an Outstanding Achievement
Award by the NIH in 2007 for the creation
of tools for data analysis in cancer biology.
And recently he participated
in the Vice President's Cancer Moonshot Project,
receiving an award from the Secretary of the
US Department of
Energy.
We're very pleased to have Ravi with us this
morning talking on Big Data Technologies For
Biomedical Knowledge
Discovery, and I encourage you in any questions
you have, either go to webinar questions submission
system,
they are located in your go-to webinar panel
off to the right on your screen.
And we'll get to some of those at the
end.
Without further ado, allow me to introduce
Ravi.
Ravi, the stage is yours.
Thank you, Jack.
Thank you for that kind introduction.
And thank you and [? Krystal ?] for having
me here.
One of the-- so let me get started.
So, I kind of wanted to take some time to
go over why we talk about big data in life
sciences and why it is
important, especially because a lot of times
researchers that work in this domain present
their results in a manner
that folks sometimes don't understand, why
investigation and investment into this kind
of infrastructure, this kind of
analysis, is important.
I'll talk a little bit about what are some
of the tools that we've dealt with as part
of the NIH Big Data to Knowledge
Center, called BDDS, and how we are developing
these tools
to create an impact and to accelerate that
discovery
process and increase our understanding on
a genetic basis for various neurogenic degenerative
disorders.
I'll put
a little bit more emphasis on the data management
and data analysis that these tools have enabled
in the context
of big data, and kind of end with some of
the results that we have generated using these
data sets.
And in the
end, I think Jack and [? Krystal ?] will come
back online to open up the floor for questions,
and I'll be happy to
answer those questions.
So, let me take a few minutes and kind of
go over why I personally think this is important.
As Jack mentioned in his
introduction, I'm a computational scientist.
I'm a senior scientist at the University of
Chicago and Argonne National
Laboratory.
We have supercomputers.
We have large-scale, high-performance computing
resources here.
And
why do I, as a computer scientist, find this
kind of Big Data Analysis in [INAUDIBLE] important?
And I'll have a few
slides where I'll present, at a high level,
why what we do is important.
So I took a little chart from the CDC, which
every year they present some of the leading
causes of death in the US,
and if you look at the chart on the left,
you see that the top two leading causes of
death are heart disease and
cancer.
The provocative statement that I want to make
here is that a good portion of these deaths
could be
preventable if they were detected early on,
or if we understood them better and were able
to see if there are any
therapeutics that that could be developed
or that are already existing that could be
re-used to lower the suffering
or to lower the deaths that are caused by
these diseases.
And one caveat that I want to say is that,
with the increase in the understanding of
how these diseases propagate
in the human body, there is a strong evidence
that shows that there is a pretty good genetic
basis for these
diseases.
So there is something in a human gene that
either causes these diseases or has a key
to reduce the
suffering that folks have to endure when they
get these diseases.
So, I do understand that I'm making a sort
of a blanket argument, because each of these,
heart disease and
cancer, research tells us they are not one
disease, there are actually multiple variations
of this disease.
Just within
heart disease, there are three types.
At least on a broader level, there are multiple
subtypes of these types.
And
and maybe folks know a bit more about cancer.
Cancer is in fact a collection of 100 or so
different types of
diseases that are grouped under one umbrella.
So, as you can see there's a big motivation
for why we have to work in this area.
And I'll talk a little bit about how
this leads into Big Data, and how Big Data
analysis and Big Data management will help
us get more
understanding about how we can make a dent
this in these disease areas.
So, this is a paper that was published in
Nature, and the authors make a statement,
and Mark, Dr. Rubin, is at
Cardinal Medical College in New York, and
they say that they found out after a lot of
data analysis that 90% of
people who are diagnosed with a type of cancer
do carry a genetic variation of mutation that
makes these patients
responsive to a known drug.
So let me kind of take a minute to let this
sink in.
So 90% of people who are suffering from cancer
that are out
there carry a genetic mutation that makes
these people respond to a known drug.
So we could be helping them if
we know what mutation this is that people
carry.
Finding out what mutation that people who
are diagnosed with
cancer carry, I argue, is a Big Data analysis
problem, and these are some of the tools that
we developed to make
it easy for us to discover the mutations that
these patients carry that may lead to prescribing
a drug that would
help them a little bit.
So that's in cancer, and if you move to the
cardiovascular diseases and a study that was
published in the New
England Journal of Medicine where they they've
done a pretty comprehensive study up of over
55,000
participants, in which they looked into the
various factors that make people susceptible
to different heart diseases.
If you look at this paper, it's pretty clear
that lifestyle choices do definitely have
the power to reduce your genetic
risk to these diseases.
But in the context of this talk the point
I'm trying to make here is that in the cardiovascular
disease area there's
been a lot of signs that help discover the
genetic risk factors that may make a person
more susceptible to the
coronary heart diseases.
So, as you can see in the top two killers
in the US, cancer and heart disease, we see
an
increase in our understanding of how various
factors, genetic factors and lifestyle factors
that affect these
diseases, would help us create therapeutics
or take existing drugs and, by being able
to discover what would be
effective for a particular subject, we can
actually do a great deal of good to folks
who are suffering or who might
be suffering from this disease.
This particular thinking is often termed as
precision medicine, where you understand the
individual risk profile and
you tailor their treatment to match their
genetic and other lifestyle factors that fit
that profile.
So Nancy Cox, the president of the American
Society of Human Genetics and longtime collaborator
for me, says
that in order to find a single mutation or
a bunch of mutations or genetic variants that
may make a person more
susceptible to cancer or coronary heart disease,
finding those mutations or finding those genetic
variants is akin to
finding a needle in a haystack, meaning that
you're essentially sifting through a lot of
data to find this one
particular data or evidence that may throw
more light into understanding a person's susceptibility
or factors that
may have affected this particular person's
disease onset.
So one of the things that folks in this area
of science do is, in order to find this needle
in a haystack, people
typically build their own infrastructure.
They build huge computing farms called private
clusters that take a lot of
time and money to build.
So in some sense, folks are building their
own haystacks, or sorting machines.
So one of the things that we argue in this
presentation is that by building your own
infrastructure, by building your
own needle haystack-sorting machine, you're
essentially spending valuable time and money
in creating
infrastructure, whereas our goal in the BDDS
project is to build services and tools that
will hopefully prevent you or
a researcher from having to build their own
infrastructure and their own tools to find
these needles in a haystack.
So these needles could be a protein that you
would be able to find using large scale proteomics
analysis, or these
needles could be a genetic marker that you
could find using large-scale genomic analysis.
And in this particular
talk, I'll take an example of a hypothesis
that our colleagues in this project from the
Institute for Systems Biology in
Seattle have made, which is to get a better
understanding of transcription regulative
factors that affect a gene to
express itself more.
Once we understand these transcription factors
better, we'll be able to build a network of
them that will help shed more light on diseases
like Alzheimer's and others.
So one of the things that I also want to emphasize
is that the needle in a haystack analogy is
getting more and
more appropriate if you look at the growth
in how much human genetic data we're collecting.
So this little graph
kind of has become a must-show in all of the
Big Data talks because it shows how the genetic
data is growing.
I keep thinking about a day when I can present
a talk without having to show this slide,
because it's kind of a little
scary and depressing because we are in no
way equipped to handle the data that we are
expected to generate in
sequencing DNA.
As you can see, one of the things that people
say is that we're collecting more data than
we
have available storage in the world.
But anyway, so this is a chart that shows
how much genetic data is growing.
And this is a little map that I put together
to show locations in the world where genetic
sequencers are operational
and are generating data.
So you might think that all of the data that
is being generated in genetics is US-centric
or
maybe generated at one place, but in fact
it's not.
All of these machines, the sequencing machines,
are distributed
geographically across the world, and all of
them are generating data.
So one of the new sequencing machines that
Illumina has released has a potential to generate
a terabyte of data
every day.
So if you can multiply that with the numbers
here, you can see how we are at an increased
rate at
which we can generate the data.
So the graph that I showed in the earlier
slide in fact could have a bigger slope
or we could be trending there much faster.
So if you look at why finding the needles
in a haystack or why finding insights In Big
Data is a challenge, you can
see-- we looked at this, we analyzed these
challenges for a long time.
This has been our area of research for 20
years now.
When we looked at some of the fundamental
challenges that researchers faced in doing
this kind of
research, there are two sets of challenges.
One is in the area of data management and
access challenges.
In genomics and proteomics, in a lot of our
research where people are trying to find these
proverbial needles, data that they need or
that they are generating
is typically distributed across the world.
So if you take the example of genetics data,
there are reference data sets
that are being used that are located in different
places and sequencing centers that are generating
this data for
researchers that I showed in the previous
slide, they are shipping hard drives full
of genetic data to researchers.
And it's a very inefficient way of moving
data.
Because if you try to move a large data set
using FedEx or one of
the older internet protocols call FTP or HTP,
you'd realize that this process takes multiple
days to move the data.
Researchers typically rely on sharing data
with each other when they collaborate and
there's this collaboration,
since sharing typically happens by putting
a web server and putting the data there.
Again, these are very
inefficient ways of sharing data with your
collaborators.
The reason why people generate data, the primary
reason, is they want to analyze this data.
And when they have
to analyze the data it could be using a cloud
computing resource or it could be using a
supercomputer.
Typically
what happens is researchers have to move the
data again into a local compute capability.
So as you can see there's a lot of movement
of data.
And you could say that oh, FedEx is very good
at moving
data.
I worked with a researcher who got their sequencing
done in China and who FedEx'ed their drive
full of
genomics data.
It got stuck in customs because they wanted
to test it to make sure it passed through.
So it takes a long time for people to get
data.
So once you have the data, you can see the
next set of challenges
in the analysis of this data, because that's
where you get the insights that you're looking
for.
And people typically
resort to writing shell scripts.
Arguably, these are people who are computationally
sophisticated, and they are
writing good shell scripts to do their analysis.
But if you look at the shell scripts there's
a lot of manual processes in
this analysis.
And whenever you have manual processes, you
know that it could be made more efficient.
So if you look at the analysis side, what
people do is typically manually move all the
data to where they could do
the analysis, they install all the tools,
and they sequentially run this analysis on
their compute clusters.
And one of
the main disadvantages for this is that, because
they are done by an individual or a team,
they're hard to
reproduce.
The knowledge that is gained is kind of lost,
or is just only available in that group.
So oftentimes the shell scripts are like toothbrushes.
You can't share toothbrushes and you can share
shell
scripts.
So it's a pretty simple analogy.
So the shell scripts and the data management,
manually moving data and
manually making the data available to your
collaborators and doing the analysis, it's
a cumbersome process that
often leads to science that is not reproducible.
When science is not reproducible, it makes
it harder for somebody
to validate your findings and build upon those
findings.
So what that means is that if I am a researcher
and I want to leverage somebody else's work,
and I want to build
on top of it, I can't do that because the
tools that you've used are making this into
a process that is not reliable to
be purchasable.
So within the BDDS, this is a little graphic
that kind of shows why having Big Data or
generating
Big Data may be very overwhelming for a researcher
to do the analysis.
What we want to do is we want to
harness the power of Big Data, and to lead
that power into ideas and to validation into
new findings.
So my goal here today is to show you how,
in the BDDS center, we are generating these
tools that allow you to
harness the power of Big Data in a way that
doesn't overwhelm you, and in a way that this
power could lead to
ideas and discoveries.
So in our center, our guiding principle is
to let the data lead you to the discoveries.
So we know that there's been a
lot of effort and time and resources spent
in generating a lot of data resources.
I'll talk a little bit about some of
these data resources and how big they are.
But it's not enough to just generate the data.
It's also important to
harness this data in a way that is reproducible
and to deliver and generate results.
So in BDDS we created a platform that allows
researchers to manage the data more efficiently.
It allows them to
create analysis pipelines and publish them
in a way such that the whole process is reproducible.
We created
ways, we created tools, that enable this discovery
process in a reproducible manner.
So these are some of the
tools that we developed.
I'll talk a little bit about each one of them
with an emphasis on one particular scientific
hypothesis that will be validated.
So the BDDS platform, as I mentioned before,
has tools in two different categories.
One is the data management
category that makes it easy for researchers
to integrate data sets from genomics, proteomics,
and image
datasets, and then end-to-end a standard format
so that you can exchange these datasets with
your collaborators
with enough metadata so they can know exactly
where this data is coming from and what this
data contains in it.
We created tools and services that allow researchers
to create reusable processes.
We created catalogs to
resource, catalogs of data for researchers
to discover what results have been created.
We created interfaces for
researchers to easily create cohorts, so for
example you want to say I want to do this
analysis on all the patients
that have this particular genetic marker,
or all the patients that are diagnosed with
lung cancer that haven't
smoked in their lives, so we created tools
that allow you to create these cohorts.
Finally we, created and operate
these services that make it easy for you to
rapidly analyze these data sets on public
cloud computing resources,
high-performance computing resources.
The key is to make these analysis pipelines
be able to be reproducible on demand so others
can build on top of
this these pipelines without having to recreate
them.
So this is the hypotheses that we worked on,
which is to get better understanding of what
are the genetic
susceptibility loci for Alzheimer's disease?
There's some meta-analysis that's been done
or for 74,000 individuals.
And we really, once we started looking at
the data, realized how little we really know.
There's been a lot of
literature on this transcriptomic regulatory
factors that do affect the genetic expression.
So we wanted to
understand how much these transcriptomic factors,
how much more insight these factors can provide
us in the
onset of Alzheimer's.
So our colleague said, yes, we have created
a method called TReNA which tries to create
a network out of this
transcriptomic regulatory factors that helps
you better reason why some of these factors
do have an impact on
Alzheimer's disease.
One of the ideas is to create a model for
every gene that you identify in this analysis,
and
use the transcript from related factors to
better explain why you see the onset of these
diseases in these subjects.
So this hypothesis has resulted in a very
comprehensive flow chart that describes radius
datasets and radius
analysis that we need to perform in order
to get the insight that we are talking about.
This pipeline was so
complicated that it didn't fit into a single
slide, even though I spent a considerable
amount of time, as you can see.
You saw this important factor box is lost.
But the idea here is that we have a series
of analysis pipelines that we need to develop.
And we have a few
datasets that are publicly available that
are generated by the NIH, including the ENCODE
dataset and the
Roadmap dataset, that have all of the raw
data that we need to analyze in order to generate
this regulatory
networks that better explain the onset of
Alzheimer's in the subjects that I mentioned
before.
So this is a pipeline, a set of analyses that
we developed, and we created a new tool called
TReNA which takes
results from all of this analysis and gives
you more evidence on, or better explanation
for, various genetic factors,
or of the proverbial needles in a haystack
we try to find using these techniques.
So I divided this into a few categories, and
data discovery is-- so as I described in one
of the slides before where
we divided this problem into a set of categories
--one category is discovery, right?
So as I mentioned, there are a
lot of existing NIH-funded databases that
have the data that we need to do this analysis.
One of those datasets is
called ENCODE.
ENCODE is a publicly available dataset which
is an encyclopedia of DNA elements.
It has a
publicly available interface, a web portal
that you can go and query for the data.
And, as you can see, it has a lot
of tissue samples that we need to do this
analysis.
One of the first things we did in order to
make it easy for us was to create these portable
data bags.
We call this
tool a BDBag, which is essentially-- as I
mentioned before, there are multiple pipelines
in this discovery process,
and we want to make it easy for us to move
that data from one analysis too, one platform,
to the next platform.
In
order for us to do that, we had to create
a mechanism to make it easy for us to portably
move datasets, metadata,
so that for every pipeline we don't have to
recreate the datasets and regenerate them
in order for us to do the
analysis.
So one of the things that we did was we looked
at how the Library of Congress handles data
archiving and data
sharing.
We looked at a product specification called
BagIt, and we extended that specification
to Big Data and we
created a BDBag specification that allows
you to create a portable data format, which
is also an acronym for .pdf,
for Big Data so that when we query ENCODE
and we generate a huge dataset that we want
to do the analysis on,
we do so as a BDBag.
We send this data back into multiple analysis
routines so we have enough metadata that
will lead to the reproducibility and reuseability
of these assets.
So the BDBag is a pretty simple concept.
It has a set of raw datasets.
It drives what data this bag is carrying.
And
the most important part of this is that it
has a checksum, which is computer science-speak
for a fingerprint, right?
So a checksum is a very unique identifier
that allows a receiver to validate that they
have received the data
without any corruption.
So the BDBag contains this portable format
in which you can take data from one platform
to another and hope that the other platform
can understand and process that data.
So we created a service on top of ENCODE so
that we can create these BDBags.
ENCODE has a few tissue
samples.
So for example, if we want to analyze lung
tissue, we can write a query to ENCODE and
it will generate a
BDBag full of data from lung tissue that we
can do the analysis on.
So now we have two things.
We have a bag full of data that has enough
metadata associated with it.
We have a
way to query and generate this bag.
Now, we move to generating an identifier for
this bag.
The reason why these
identifiers are important is that these are
the things that you're recording so that when
you publish your results or
your pipeline there are identifiers that allows
somebody to validate that yes, this exists
and this is expected.
This is
as this research team is claiming it to be.
So we created a service that allows you to
create these identifiers.
Every data item that you have seen in this
huge pipeline that I showed before has an
identifier assigned to it.
This is a digital identifier.
You can reference it,
you can share it with your collaborators,
and you can resolve it.
This makes very this makes it very easy for
you to
share Big Data sets.
When you have a minimal identifier, you just
send that minid to your collaborator and they
can resolve it.
This solves the problem that I mentioned before
where you're setting up an FTP sever or some
other format to make it easy for you to share
data.
So this shows how you can resolve a minimal
identifier, and more importantly choose the
metadata that is
available with this identifier.
So it has a unique identifier.
We use something called ARK to generate this.
It shows
when this bag is created, it shows who created
it, and this identifier next to Kyle has what
is called an Arcade,
which is a research identifier that uniquely
identifies Kyle as a researcher at the University
of Chicago.
It provides
a checksum, and it provides a location in
which you can download this bag.
Right now this bag is located on
Amazon.
You could use Amazon data access mechanisms
to retrieve this bag.
So in order to make it easy for researchers,
we generated a lot of tools to generate these
identifiers.
So now that
we have the bag and we have the identifiers
that uniquely identifies a bag, now we move
to the next level of how
do we move this data, and how do we reliably
share these bags with researchers?
One of the challenges that we have in Big
Data is the bag that we generated was around
23 terabytes of data,
right?
So it's not small enough for you to carry
around in a USB stick.
It's not small enough for you to download
it
in a FTP server.
We tried, and it took us more than a few weeks,
and the transfer never succeeded because these
are inherently unreliable ways of moving data.
So we built a service that makes it easy for
you to manage, share, and transfer your datasets.
It's called Globus.
Globus is a data management service that makes
it easy for researchers to move Big Data easily
without having
to become experts in Unix.
It also makes it easy for researchers to share
datasets with each other reliably.
In the
later part of the talk I'll talk about some
of the additional services we built where
researchers can publish their
results and others can discover them using
some of the management services we created
and operate.
So as I said before, Globus makes it easy
for researchers to do large-scale data transfers.
It provides secure
access with the multi-tier security model.
And one of the important things that we've
done is we have improved the
performance with which you can move data.
So you can move a lot of data really quickly.
So this is a graphic that
shows improved performance and comparison
with existing data streams, with existing
data protocols, and how
quickly you can move data.
So, as you can see, GridFTP, which is a protocol
that we use to move data in Globus,
outperforms traditional data transfer protocols.
So this is an interface for searching.
This is a Big Data repository where researchers
can publish their datasets
with metadata and others can look into it
and discover them.
And when I talk about that the TReNA pipeline,
I'll
show how we have leveraged all of these services,
how we leverage Globus transfer to move the
raw data from
ENCODE into Amazon cloud storage, and how
we were able to leverage our analysis service
to run large-scale
analysis, how we generated minids for them,
and how we generated results and published
them into these data
repositories for others to find them.
So this is a process in which somebody would
publish their datasets into the Globus publication
service.
So
Globus is pretty widely used across the research
enterprise.
Over 190 petabytes of data have been moved.
billion files were processed.
It has over 50,000 registered users and enjoys
a lot of uptime because we run this as
a production quality service that the researchers
can depend on for managing their Big Data
.
So lets move to the how, now that we figured
out a way to generate unique identifiers,
to generate portable data
formats for these raw ENCODE datasets, of
all of this is in support of finding those
needles in a Haystack.
So we
built this service called Globus Genomics
that combines Globus data management and analysis
on the cloud
using a tool called Galaxy.
So using this service, researchers can get
the data bags that they have generated from
ENCODE service.
They
can build a scalable analysis pipeline that
runs on all cloud computing resources.
One of the important innovations
that we have done is that by understanding
the computational capabilities of these tools,
we were able to schedule
these analyses to be run on cloud resources
at a very small price using spot market.
So you could do large-scale
Big Data analysis without having to pay a
lot of dollars for compute.
So how do we, now that we have seen all of
these building blocks of doing Big Data analysis,
bring them all to
bear for validating this one hypothesis that
I presented before?
So we created a small chart that explains
how
we've done it.
We created a interface that will allow researchers
to query the ENCODE dataset, create a bag,
and
use that bag to send that to the Globus genomic
service that I showed before.
And the service will allow
researchers to assemble a pipeline of analysis
that will take this BDBag, do the analysis
at scale on a cloud
computing resource, and generate a bag of
results that show how these transcriptomic
regulatory networks are
affecting various genetic loci for Alzheimer's
disease.
We take these networks and we publish them
in a publication service and we take the raw
data that we generate
and publish them into the DERIVA service that
University of Southern California manages
so others can discover
them and query them easily.
So just to remind you, this is a pipeline
that we are attempting to build in the Globus
genomic service.
We ended
up creating one which takes-- this is pipeline
in the bottom half of the picture --and it
takes the minid as an input,
the minid is the ID for the BDBag that we
have generated from the ENCODE data repository.
So this minid could
represent all of the raw datasets for a particular
organ that a researcher is interested in.
We run this analysis at
scale, and we generate the transcriptomic
regulatory network model that will help researchers
to get a better
understanding of how these genetic loci factor
in the onset of Alzheimer's.
So this is how we run it at scale on all of
the datasets.
And I have a slide that shows the scale at
which we run it.
So once we have these results, we can essentially
do, we generated a bag of results.
So this bag is created by a
colleague of mine at the University of Chicago.
As I have shown before, that the bag of raw
input was generated
by Kyle, but the bag of results is created
by Alex.
What was the BDBag allows you to do is that
multiple
collaborators can work and be able to exchange
datasets with ease with each other with enough
metadata.
So this particular bag refers to lymphoblast
cell, with the footprinting results from those,
or the transcriptomic
regulatory networks for that particular tissue.
We also built a catalog that makes it easy
for researchers to query these results.
So for example, within ENCODE
we have generated results for 26 tissue types.
And these results span from genetic sets,
proteomic datasets, but if
a researcher is trying to narrow down a particular
area of interest, it's often hard for them
to sift through
thousands of files in order to find that data.
We built a catalog called DERIVA that catalogs
using the metadata of all of these datasets,
catalogs all the data,
and provides a nice and easy-to-use interface
that allows researchers to query for particular
aspects of the data
and do further downstream analysis of this
data.
I talked about the data repository before.
This is another mechanism for publishing the
findings of a research
paper.
If somebody is reading your paper, we will
provide the links to a repository.
They can go to this repository
to find the results.
That helps them to build on your research
or on your findings.
So, in conclusion, with this particular analysis,
there are 26 tissue types, but they correspond
to 206 tissue
samples.
The total amount of data we have analyzed
is around 2.5 terabytes.
We created a lot of tools and highperformance
computing workflows that ran at scale on Amazon
cloud resources.
And the important thing in this slide is that
we created 106 publicly available databases
that provide this regulated
reference for all of the tissue samples that
are available in code.
This will help others to build on using these
databases without recreating them.
So, in conclusion, the BDDS center is comprised
of experts in various life sciences research
and computer
science.
Our goal is to provide a streamlined approach
for Big Data management, aggregation, manipulation,
integration, and modeling of various biological
systems across patients and temporal scales.
So thank you for taking time to think today,
and I'd be happy to answer any questions that
you may have.
Thank you so much Ravi.
That was a really great overview of a very
interesting ecosystem for being able to
manage, manipulate, and process large-scale
biomedical data.
I encourage everybody who's listening to submit
a
question, again using the go-to webinar question
submission system.
In the meantime, Ravi, you mentioned something
about the bags, the BDBags system.
I'm curious how the bag
system differentiates itself from just like
a classic kind of TAR file?
And if those are published someplace and they
act as kind of a centralized thing, what happens
if somebody updates those files and then all
of a sudden, the data
that I was expecting is now different?
How is that documented and reported back to
the end users?
Yeah, that's a great question.
So one of the important differences between
a .tar file and a bag is that the bag, in
addition to containing the list of the raw
datasets, it also contains checksums for all
of those datasets, and a
checksum for the bag itself.
So for example, if you change the file or
if you change the collection that the bag
refers to, the checksums don't
match anymore.
So if somebody were to download a TAR file
today, and the generator of the TAR file changed
that to a different-- added or deleted some
data in that TAR file --if you download it
tomorrow, you could look at
both the TAR files and they would be the same,
but when you include the checksum within the
TAR file, you can
say that yes, this file has changed since
the last time I touched it.
So that's one big differentiator between a
bag
and a TAR file.
The second thing is that a bag also has a
minid associated with it.
This is a unique identifier that has more
metadata associated with it, in terms of who
created this bag, where is this bag located,
when was this created,
and the checksum for the data that was in
that bag.
This makes it a lot more powerful when you
care about the
reproducibility of research.
Also, are there any dependencies on the type
of workflow engine that's being deployed?
So I mean you
mentioned Galaxy, obviously, which is widely
popular for genetics and for other things.
I'm curious if other
workflow engines are suitable here.
Can describe anything that's been done with
other systems?
Yeah, no, that's a great question.
So no, so the bag, the BDBag tool and the
format is not dependent on one
workflow.
So we have work done to make the LONI pipeline,
which is a very popular tool to do large-scale
image
analysis.
They have used the BDBag format and tools
to exchange large image datasets.
So it's not just
constrained to a tool or a technology, it
is a pretty general purpose tool.
That's great.
Send in any questions that you might have,
folks.
One other thing I was curious about is, where
are these jobs run?
I mean, I presume that at University of Chicago
and at Argonne, you've got giant computers,
warehouses full of computers where this stuff
can run.
Are these the
types of things which can be deployed to other
institutions, or is it solely dependent upon
your cluster?
Or could it
run on my Amazon account or my Google Cloud
accounts?
Yes, so as I mentioned, one of the things
that we've done in our work is we realize
that we don't want to build a
haystack sorting machine for everybody.
I mean, to some extent, if everybody decides
to build their own machine,
then it takes a long time to do science.
So all of the tools, Globus and Globus genomics
that are all services that are running on
Amazon.
And if you want
to run it on your own, at least Globus genomics,
you can run it in your Amazon account.
So there are some
operational tools that we have built to make
these services reliable and make them run
at scale on public cloud
computing resources.
And where can we find these resources if we're
interested in investigating them ourselves?
I should have put a link for to the BDDS tools
web page.
I should have put it in my slides.
But the BDDS center
website has a tools section where you can
find all of the tools and GitHub repositories
where they are located.
Fantastic, and where can we find Globus and
the Globus tools?
Globus.org is the website.
And this is sort of a little bit of a different
question.
In the context, I mean we have these webinars
in the context of
biomedical data science, but I'm curious if
through Globus and through other initiatives
that you guys are involved
with there at the University of Chicago and
with Argonne, that you must be dealing with
other scientific data types,
whether it's particle physics or astrophysics
or something else that generates massive-scale
data.
I'm curious if,
do you have any lessons learned from those
data types or those scientific domains which
are helpful as
biomedical scientists deal with the ever-increasingly
large datasets?
Yeah, definitely.
One of the great things about working at Argonne
and University of Chicago is that there are
a lot
of great sciences that happened here.
Traditionally we have worked very closely
with the Large Hadron Collider
on particle physics, on discovery of Higgs-Boson.
And a lot of lessons learned in Big Data management,
and highenergy
physics, and on earthquake sciences, and climate
modeling, those were sort of the lessons that
have
resulted in the tools and services that we've
built.
It's interesting you say, so in the high [INAUDIBLE]
physics there is one central location in CERN
where Big Data is
being generated.
This particle collider is generating petabytes
of data.
And one of the early things that they have
done is every institution in the world that
is doing research in particle physics started
building their own
infrastructure.
They quickly realized that there's no way
they can host all the data they need.
They can't run all the
compute they need.
They created what is called a [INAUDIBLE]
grid, which is a distributed multi-tier model
that
has streamlined managing data, moving data
to multiple centers across the world, and
distributing the compute
that is required to gain the insights.
If you been following the press lately, we
were involved in building infrastructure for
LIGO, which was in the press
recently for discovering gravitational waves.
And this is a similar approach that the gravitational
physicists have
taken in order to gain insights from the data
they're generating.
I realize, you know life sciences, they're
still, in the
grand scale of Big Data sciences, life sciences
is sort of a newcomer, especially with the
advent of next-Gen
sequencing and large-scale MRI machines that
are generating a lot more data.
But this is the expertise that we gathered
from working with various other domains.
And we think it has a lot of
impact and use in the life sciences, too.
We don't have to relearn every lesson that
is learned across all the other
domains just because we have an un-inventive
attitude.
Our goal is to sort of bring some of the lessons
that we
learned from other domains to bring to bear,
to accelerate the discovery process in life
sciences, mostly because
the discoveries that we make in life sciences
have a great impact in human health.
That makes it very personal.
Oh, absolutely, I think the holy grail of
large-scale data science for biomedicine is
to do something like discover a
Higgs-Boson, or find gravitational waves,
or have some big results that could not have
existed unless we had
marshaled massive amounts of data and figured
out how to leverage large-scale computing,
move data only when
needed, apply workflow technologies, and to
be able to model things such that we can make
those kinds of
discoveries.
That would be a wonderful outcome.
And I think what you've described here looks
like we're well
down the path of getting towards that special
day when something like that happens and we
cure cancer, or we
get some insight into disease or diabetes,
or something else.
So thank you for sharing this exciting ecosystem
for discovery science, Ravi, really appreciate
it.
And with that
we've kind of reached the end of our hour.
I want to thank everyone for tuning in, and
please look forward to
future speakers and our BD2K guide to the
fundamentals of data science.
We'll see you next time.
Thank you
everyone, and thank you Ravi.
Thank you.